desde que se hizo efectivo el divorcio
con bruselas el primero de enero de este
año cualquier envío de un producto
alimenticio o un bien desde cualquier
ciudad británica a irlanda del norte que
es el mismo país es considerado un tipo
de exportación por todos los trámites
que se requieren esto porque irlanda del
norte después de la firma del break si
permanece dentro del mercado único de la
unión europea y también dentro de su
sistema aduanero esto para evitar que se
revivieron las rencillas del pasado
instalando una frontera física en esta
zona y que diera paso y que pusiera en
riesgo el acuerdo de paz de 1998 que
trajo paz política a esa zona tras más
de 30 años de conflicto y de 3.500
muertos por supuesto este protocolo ha
generado que desde los primeros meses de
este 2010 y no hay además
desabastecimiento de alimentos básicos y
también confrontación política
especialmente entre los partidos
unionistas que creen que él en un nido
está en peligro